so if I was to ask you right enough an
enemy wanted to attack our country U.S
let's just say how would they do it you
may say well Pat they're going to do
cyber they're going to do bio Warfare no
they're going to do nuclear what if I
told you they could do it with water if
U.S had a Water Crisis and you and I
don't have water you know how long we
can go without water three days some say
up to a week but most studies say three
days and one of the biggest crisis we're
dealing with right now worldwide is what
a crisis when I show you some of the
statistics on what it's looking like
when you watch the movie Big Short if
you remember the movie Big Show with
Michael burry one of the biggest
investors at everybody worldwide follows
he's got this hedge fund called Scion
hedge fund that I think he manages
nearly two billion dollars you know
what's what it said at the end of the
movie they said Michael burry his next
investment and commodity that he's
focused on is only one thing and what do
you think it was water we're gonna take
a deep dive why so many people around
the world are worried about the Water
Crisis
thank you
okay so if you get value out of this
video give it a thumbs up subscribe to
the channel let's get right into it
according to a U.N Water conference the
world faces a 40 shortfall in fresh
water supply by 2030 and when we break
down water on how much we use worldwide
we use more than 4 trillion cubic meters
of fresh water per year and just to kind
of put that in context on how much 4
trillion cubic meters is one cubic meter
equals 264 gallons of water one cubic
meter so now let's continue Pat what do
you mean by all this water don't we have
all this water the ocean why should we
be worried about water 71 of earth's
surface is covered by water that should
be good news no well there's a
difference between what kind of water we
drink watch this 97 of Earth's water or
salt water two percent is fresh water
trapped in glaciers point six five
percent is the fresh water that we use
for everything such as drinking let's
focus on this 0.65 where do we get this
fresh water from here's what it looks
like 75 of it is withdrawn on each year
from rivers lakes and reservoirs 25
percent comes from groundwater aquifers
and 80 percent of water withdrawn in the
U.S is used for cooling electric power
plants and for irrigation so I just want
to give you a visual here when you look
at to the reservoirs the largest
reservoirs we have in U.S you'll see
Lake Mead and Lake Powell and if you
look at these pictures both of them have
experienced critically low levels
recently here's what it looks like in
2000 versus today in 2000 these two
reservoirs were full 95 they were full
today they're roughly 25 percent said
Brad Udall a watering climate scientist
at Colorado State University it's hard
to overstate how important the Colorado
River is to the entire American
southwest now you may say I'm not a math
cat look 95 just 23 years ago today 25
no matter what the numbers that's not a
good thing on what the numbers are
looking like where we've gone to where
we are today today's sponsor is better
health and it's interesting because just
today we were on a podcast and one of
the articles that we read by Wall Street
Journal said that four out of ten
Americans don't have a best friend what
does that mean and couple months ago
another article came out talking about
the lonely epidemic people don't have
somebody to talk to during Kobe we were
alone we were by ourselves half the time
you need somebody to talk to even as a
business owner entrepreneur founder
myself the last 20 years many times I've
been by myself I can't talk to my wife I
can't talk to my family I chose to start
a business who am I going to go complain
to sometimes you just need somebody to
talk to what better help does is on
their website betterhelp offers 30 000
license and experienced therapists you
get to pick and choose the questionnaire
you get to pick and choose the topics
you answer a certain set of questions
and they match it with therapists that
are best suited for you and then from
there you get to have a conversation
with somebody and if it doesn't work out
for you they'll replace it with somebody
else as well so if this is something
that you're dealing with you want to
talk to somebody go to betterhelp.com
forward slash value Tim you'll get 10
discount on your first month again go to
betterhub.com forward slash value Tim
you'll get 10 discount on your first
month so now let's take a look at how
much water we domestic basically have
been withdrawn since 1960 when you look
at this chart here's what it shows if
you look at the dark blue it's domestic
and Industrial then total irrigation and
livestock so obviously 600 increase
since 1960 that's 73 years ago to today
that's not a good thing to see however
70 percent of freshwater withdrawals are
used for agricultural purposes 20 for
industrial use the rest of the 10
percent used for domestic you and I
drink in Water by 2050 water demand is
expected to increase from 20 to 30
percent and by the way when we're saying
2050 I want to show you what the
comparable was of where we were in 2010
and what they're expecting to be by 2015
2010 1.9 billion people lived in
severely water scarce places and this
number is expected to increase to 3.2
billion by 2050. so now if you wanted to
find out where is the freshwater
scarcity Trend worldwide here here's
what we would look at if we look at this
chart here you will look at the numbers
to the right that says 100 so Northern
Africa 100 Middle East South Asia
they're not in a good place and second
Wars will be East Asia and you could
look at Southern Africa and if you were
to say which ones are the best you got
North America South America and
Australia Pacific all at 25 now when you
look at this you know the issue with
water there's been many scandals of
water over the years I'll give you one
of them especially with Nestle when it
was discovered that Flint Michigan's let
tainted pipes created a local Water
Crisis the government originally gave
out free bottled waters but it
eventually ended and at the same time
Department of Environmental Quality had
a prudent Nestle's request to increase
the amount of water it pumps from the
great lakes in the same month the state
decided to stop giving free bottled
water to Flint it was effectively
deciding to give away millions of
gallons to multinational corporation
besides a one-time five thousand dollar
permit application fee under Michigan
law Nestle the largest food and beverage
company in the world must pay the state
only 200 every year administrative fee
to bottle and sell 400 gallons a minute
of Michigan groundwater and that's just
Nestle in Michigan now let's look at
Nestle in California Nestle has
maintained that its rights to California
Spring Water date back to 1865 but a
2017 investigation found that Nestle was
taking far more than its share in 2020
the company Drew out about 58 million
gallons far surpassing the 2.3 million
gallons a year it could validly claim
according to the report Nestle has taken
on average 25 times as much water as it
may have a right too according to the
story of a stuffed project and
environmental group that has been
fighting to stop the bottle Water
Company's operation in California for
years while California is facing record
droughts and wildfires so now every time
there's a crisis there's opportunity why
because a capitalist or an entrepreneur
can come in and say let's solve this
problem if we can solve this problem
there could be a lot of incentives for
it as well so watch what's been
happening with this Matthew deseri the
president and co-founder of the hedge
fund water Asset Management that's
literally what it's called called the
U.S water business the biggest Emerging
Market on earth a trillion dollar market
opportunity in matter of fact like I
told you earlier even Michael burry at
the end of the movie and big short said
that his Focus had become on one
commodity and that is water here's what
he said in an interview in 2015.
transporting water is Impractical for
both political and physical reasons so
buying up water rights did not make a
lot of sense to me what became clear to
me is that food is the way to invest in
water that is grow food and water-rich
areas and transport it for sale in water
poor areas this is the method for
redistributing water that is least
contentious and ultimately can be
profitable which will ensure that this
redistribution is sustainable and he
said the following about wine those of
you guys that drink wine you ready for
this a bottle of wine takes over 400
bottles of water to produce the water
embedded in food is what I have found
interesting so it just tells you guys
that are thinkers they're going to see
opportunities to fix this problem which
means that's a good thing for us long
term there are three ways to invest into
water number one purchasing water rides
number to invest in water Rich farmland
and number three is invest in water
utilities infrastructure and equipment
so now one of the technologies that can
solve the problem is a process called
the desalination which is a process by
which the dissolved mineral salts in
water are removed currently this process
applied to seawater one of the most used
to obtain fresh water for human
consumption or agriculture purposes so
if you look at this flow here step
number one is seawater intake step
number two the intake screening facility
then it's pre-treatment filters then
it's reverse osmosis membrane units
remove salt and other impurities from
water in them step number five is post
treatment to drinking water standard
then you got step number six drinking
water supply tank and last but not least
step number seven seawater concentrate
Outlet all of this process turns
seawater into drinking water it looks
like a technical process but one of the
largest desalination plants in the world
is soric desalination plant is located
south of Tel Aviv Israel and it produces
137 million gallons of potable water a
day and the largest plant we have in the
U.S is in Carlsbad San Diego which
produces is roughly 50 million gallons
of water per day so this is all good
news because once you know the world
found out that this was a problem people
started looking into us and this started
in 1960 and if you look at this chart
here you'll see the growth of
desalination globally from 1960 to 2020
it's climbing and the cost of
desalinated water has been coming down
as a technology of all matter of fact in
the last three decades the cost of
desalination has dropped by more than
half and even globally more than 300
million people now get their water from
desalination plants from the U.S
Southwest to China but there are some
that focus on more than others such as
Saudi Arabia which produces 20 percent
of the world's desalinated water with a
9 million cubic meters produced per day
60 of its water is desalinated and
according to statista if you look at
this Saudi Arabia is investing heavily
in desalination here's what it's looking
like if you look at the left you'll see
Saudi Arabia at the top then it's UAE
Dennis Jordan Egypt Oman Morocco Tunisia
Algeria Kuwait and others so when you're
looking at this of course any way we see
as a solution you think about it and say
okay the future looks bad there's people
that are working on this now there's
certain people that say there's
downsides to desalination with one of
them being it uses a lot of energy could
be bad for the environment it hurts to
fish desalinated water is more expensive
than imported water and for every gallon
of fresh water created one and a half
gallons of salt water was created and
sent back into the ocean and some argue
that this is a problem and the state of
California has increasingly taken an
anti-disalination position citing
environmental reasons so so final
thoughts on this water on how I'm
processing it number one I trust
capitalism what I mean by capitalism
whoever is going to be negatively
impacted by this has to fix this so
let's look at drink companies who would
be negatively impacted by this coffee
relies on water so that's who Coffee
Bean Starbucks 7-Eleven soda is going to
be impacted by this which is who
Coca-Cola Pepsi all the other guys that
got to figure this out water companies
are going to be impacted there's so many
companies that are going to be impacted
by this if it got so bad they would all
gather their resources to figure out a
way to fight against the Water Crisis so
that's one there's too much money
involved that there's no way they're
going to allow this to happen number two
technology advancement I was at Harvard
one guy sitting there from Lagos and he
says here's what we created we're
raising money right now each plant is a
hundred million dollars and we're able
to raise this much money and if we do
this this is how many gallons of water
we can produce on a daily basis like
okay this is good it was a creative way
that they were doing it creating clouds
and all this stuff now very interesting
the way he was doing it it was very
different than desalination but outside
of that I only give you a project an
operation that the CIA worked on in the
60s called operation Popeye I don't know
if you've heard about this or not but
we've known how to make rain fake rain
look real for decades and we've kept it
kind of on the hush hush and we use
words such as allegedly but let me kind
of read this to you so you can kind of
get an idea what this operation Popeye
was about it wasn't about the Popeye
with the big Forum you're talking about
it's a different kind of a Popeye so
operation Popeye was a military cloud
seeding project carried out by the U.S
Air Force during the Vietnam War in 1967
to 72 the highly classified program
attempted to extend the monsoon season
over specific areas of the Ho Chi Minh
trail in order to disrupt the North
Vietnamese military supplies by
softening roads surfaces and causing
landslides the former U.S Secretary of
Defense Robert McNamara was aware that
there might be objections raised by the
international scientific Community but
said in a memo to the president that
such objections had not in the past been
a basis for prevention of military
activities considered to be in the
interest of U.S national security and
the chemical weather modification
program was conducted from Thailand over
Cambodia Laos in Vietnam and allegedly
sponsored by Secretary of State Henry
Kissinger and the CIA without the
authorization of then Secretary of
Defense Melvin Laird who had
categorically denied to Congress that a
program for modification of weather for
use as tactical weapon ever existed so
remember keyword allegedly right
allegedly that this happened but if
that's something they did back in the
days and it turned into a story like
this that means there's plenty of people
that have the technology that if they
really wanted to create rain and even
Michio Kaku had on the podcast before we
interviewed him he was once sitting down
and I think it's with good morning USA
Good Morning America whatever the show
is and he's explaining to them how
through Laser Technology they're able to
manipulate to create rain and this has
been around for a long time and we can
do this today so again advancement I
trust it's out there capitalists I trust
are going to figure out a way through
using technology and I just want to put
this one thought in your head for you to
be thinking about because I truly
believe only the paranoid survived which
is what Andy Grove said FDR once said
the following in politics nothing
happens by accident if it happens you
can bet it was planned that way why am I
saying that quote to you if in the
future you all of a sudden find yourself
with news that's being shared to you to
scare you with Water Crisis and this is
why we have to whatever shut down eat
you know mosquitoes or eat this or eat
that or whatever way they're going to
try to figure out to scare the hell out
of you always go back to wait a minute
we've been able to create rain we've
been able to do all this stuff for so
many different decades why are you using
the scare Tech they just go back to you
know what the solutions are put that
together don't use another crisis to be
able to control me and scare the crap
out of me so I can vote for you be
tempted to question and push back when
somebody uses that crisis against you
having said that if you got value out of
this video give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel if you've never
seen the video we did on a vertical Farm
an Incredible video we did on vertical
farming it's another crisis that has to
do with farming if you've not seen it
click here to watch it take care
everybody bye bye
foreign